[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys well we're extremely
careful here
and we got kunal dudette clearing the
scene over here no
no hey i heard your nickname was krypto
kunal oh
wait we told you that i just made that
up
he's just made up a fact because i know
uh you don't have all this we were
talking about crypto just before this
because you know it's an exciting time
for
some people in the crypto scene what
steve why don't you let us know what's
going on look look it's look it's just
one of those things where you know
you've been writing about something it's
been pretty awesome pretty rare and and
you know a lot of people to a t though a
lot of people thought that maybe you
weren't as good as something as maybe
you were and then you know now the
proof's in the pudding dude like [ __ ]
tons of people made [ __ ] tons of money i
think i me i mean dude
i can't even count the amount of
millionaires i made on on two hands i'm
not kidding so so that's kind of wild to
be in this to be sitting here hello oh
oh it's it's con artist steve talking
wait what did you do damn you made too
many people money oh i hate you
i hate you so much it's great look it's
one of those things where it's awesome
because i was i was i really believed in
this project specifically for a long
time like this whole basically almost a
year now just about um it's over it's
been over a year since today anyway um
but i i got you wearing the hat we're in
the hat
i've been in this hat
forever like slight turn on it too it's
like the swag turn yeah like february of
last year i got this hat
you know i haven't watched it since i
don't even worry about it you can tell
it's crazy uh but no but but the point
is is that like you know when you find
something
you know in crypto especially you're
looking for edges in the market
something that people don't see yet
right so tara luna this whole time that
we've been talking about luna and you
guys all know we've been talking about
like for a long time
um it's had a key edge in the market
one's called anchor protocol where you
can take your money right now and so you
have like a savings account right and
you're losing seven point what five
percent right now to inflation well
guess what with terre luna you're
getting nineteen point three percent so
you're beating inflation damn right and
so bank all the interest banking doesn't
offer that banking hates you just for
having your money sitting there they do
they're they're colluding together to
make sure that when you put your money
into their into your account they you
it's immediately gone they use your
money to make 10 a year and they don't
give you any of it so they cause they
[ __ ] hate you hold on these guys
sound white
these guys down what uh if only they had
the same kind of white principles that
might
[Laughter]
exploration thank you
uh um
yeah what was it matt damon says it's
like the fortune favors the bold i'm
like jesus oh for the crypto.com pisses
me off about crypto right now is like
everyone's saying like hey
you know you know crypto is
you go up to vegas i like this guy you
go to the roo you go to the roulette
table
you put down your [ __ ] money we'll
see what happens you know
unless you didn't do it well my dad did
he worked at a gas station all right he
died and it's like dude that's not
what's going on i'm betting here
if you don't know what defy is if you
don't know what decentralized finance is
you're missing out on what people are
getting right now like aprs apys like
the amount of of yield that they can get
for their money
is no longer involved with their bank
account so so your financial system is
being replicated right now on the
blockchain you maybe don't know that yet
but that's what's going on that's why
it's exciting still
and all the all these new protocols that
are being invented like anchor protocol
is super beneficial to a lot of people
who are just chilling at home right now
going what can i do to make to have my
money make me more money right and and
you might say steve that's [ __ ] up
crypto's volatile i don't know [ __ ] well
no no anchor protocol is like you take
your money into a stable coin called ust
it's the fastest growing stable coin off
crypto look it up oh by the way we were
talking about the whole [ __ ] time too
in my crypto corner so that's all it's
just it just feels so good
[Music]
i don't know i love i love the passion
and the energy coming from steve i want
to throw a little bit of back that
context for our fans
no [ __ ] like
the reason why we're even talking about
this right now is because just before
the cameras turned on steve and joe and
everybody here was talking about like yo
we got to like show this thing because
we really want to make sure that people
especially our fans are are still in
tune with the things that we strongly
believe in so that they can benefit
their own lives this is fully financial
advice you could totally sue no this is
not financial advice
not financially
i said the wrong line my bad yeah thank
you okay not financially for legal
purposes we can never give financial
advice ever on this channel but but i
will say crypto is a very very relevant
topic again especially during the russia
ukraine conflict right because like
there's a lot of uh i would i think a
lot of you guys would agree a lot of
weird misinformation going on out there
about like you know russia using crypto
to evade sanctions and like all this
weird [ __ ] and and it randomly throwing
buzz into the space but it's also
pumping the space well yeah because
ukraine is also using crypto as a way to
get donations i think
right now they got over like 17 million
over 20 million 20 million okay but
that's going fast and they had an ether
wallet they had a bitcoin wallet i think
they had a
one more a usdt i think oh really
well they should have a ust wallet yeah
they should but then they can put on
anchor for 19.3 but that's fine
but i think that's the beauty of
decentralizing the finances you no
longer have a government or entity or
small group of people who can control
the money supply so like yes it can be
used by maybe tyrannical governments but
it can also be used by people who don't
have access because their banks aren't
open and they need the help and people
talking about russia is using crypto
to pay for the war dude they're they you
have to amass a certain war chest to pay
for a war they're using oil money the
whole reason why
they could pay for this war is because
the price of oil is a goddamn nut
like [ __ ] and guess what we're still
buying their oil do we have to because
we we cut domestics
of the world right damn right germany's
doing something germany's main
gas supply is russia and even though
they're made a member of the un and nato
they europe is dependent on russian oil
so guess who's helping pay for the war
europe buying russian oil that's the
whole [ __ ] game so
that's what that's what drives me nuts
about all this stuff too is people just
look at the interim so like oh they just
froze all these russian accounts now
russia's maybe going into crypto cool
they still can't pay for [ __ ] with it
that way yeah you're talking about what
they can you do a tornado cache like
exit which is like and if they're using
crypto they're literally putting it on a
public ledger exactly you can track
everything like why would you do that if
you're trying to [ __ ] and that whole
[ __ ] about like oh it's only being
used by drug dealers and whatever that's
old like they're not that's still there
no
who says that anymore they're not saying
that [ __ ] anymore it's not like they go
into drug dens and they find ledger nano
asses bro they find [ __ ] wads of cash
you want to be finding my [ __ ] nano s is
a cold wallet where you store your
crypto just in case you don't know thank
you
but aside from all the like political
and you know
you can also find that on amazon so if
you can buy ledgers on amazon yeah
that's right
amazon is an ecommerce
just so you know
if you
if you do do that make sure the box is
not tampered with and make sure that you
factory reset the device before you use
it because oh huge scam on amazon where
people are
are taking your ledger and they will
actually set it up and then they'll give
you this populated um seed address and
like hey this is this is your seat
address you're all good and then you
onboard money into that ledger and then
they it's gone and then so long shivan
has nothing to do with this steel it has
nothing to do with the firmware or
anything like that going on with ledger
it has everything to do with it was
tampered with before you got it you know
why i think crypto gets a bad rep though
i mean stocks gets a bad rep there's
people today that still feel like stocks
are a bunch of scams yeah right but like
okay so so i know right it's a [ __ ]
hundreds of years old or whatever but
like so when you look at crypto
uh anything that is like currently
growing currently kind of beta stage
currently like booming right there's a
lot of testing going on but also it
attracts a lot anything that attracts a
lot of money also attracts a lot of con
artists that want fast money because
there's just a lot of greed going on in
it right same thing happened during the
dot-com bubble same thing happens to
every kind of bubble so like
the thing is when people just make this
blanket statement go crypto is a scam
like
you're really selling yourself short
you're just writing off an entire
industry that you don't know anything
about because you're afraid of it
because you heard some story that one
person has like it or even a couple
people have right but
i've never been i mean i'm not inviting
anybody to [ __ ] with me but i but look
i've been very careful with the way
though
with the way that i do crypto
transactions because i'm aware of how
the scams can work and how you can get
like exploited so i got scammed you did
what happened
uh you met a girl on whatsapp yeah damn
[ __ ]
said hey wrong number five std um no i
uh when i started getting when i first
got into like defy stuff um i
uh
it was it was like a it was a new um
a new crypto that was like being offered
or whatever but then it was a fake um
uh what's it called url uh
fake um on uniswap like a fake
coin or it was it was just degenerate it
was on decks tools right and dextools uh
is like
kind of sketchy sometimes because people
can kind of upload any shows union swap
yeah it's the same [ __ ] yeah that stands
for decentralized exchange
and so it was it was just the wrong one
it was a fake one and so all these
people put money into it right away and
it just
immediately after a couple hours it just
was locked and so all of our money
mean albaro did this we woke up like
early too it was like 6 a.m we're like
oh it's it's going to be public at 6 a.m
and we woke up early and we're like got
it and it was it was the wrong one and
so our our money is just lost
but it's like
you know but then that's just going to
be a tax write-off so whatever you know
oh wow you can write you're going to
write scams off as a tax riser loss
that's cool a loss is a loss dude well
it's called tax loss harvesting i mean
you can um you can write down a lot of
the things that that you sold at a loss
potentially and then you lock it in you
can report it there and again i think
that uh again just for the sake of
everybody who's watching i think this is
a really really important conversation
to have during this time because we've
just seen a lot of updates i know we've
been like showing things like luna and
crypto and stuff like that over over a
year now you know what i'm saying
steve's been doing a great job just like
even educating people like myself
getting into the space and there's been
amazing games i'm not gonna lie shit's
been pretty sick oh yeah at the same
time we happen to be living in a you
know very turbulent time frame when
we're looking at things that he's been
bringing up like uh like canada right
like like things like gofundme where
you're looking at assets um being
categorized as
terrorism very patriot act like you know
what i mean yeah the guise of terrorism
some central authority or dictator type
of authority can choose to just freeze
money like the idea today's video is
brought to you by off start
if you got multiple credit card balances
each month and are getting by just by
paying the minimums barely making a debt
into your credit card debt it could be
pretty dang discouraging upstart can
help you pay off your existing debt so
you can feel like you're finally getting
ahead whether you're paying off credit
cards consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
that you're more than just your credit
score and is expanding access to
affordable credit unlike other lenders
upstart considers your income and
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
rate check you can see your rate up
front for loans from one thousand all
the way up to fifty thousand dollars wow
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record
to me it's like regardless of how you
feel about politics right i feel that in
a in a modern western nation right we're
taught these like independent freedoms
and rights and of private ownership and
whatever right
and so imagine if the truckers
if if they did what they did to the
truckers to the blm movement
would they be treated the same way from
the public like the truckers got their
accounts seized they found out who
individually was protesting and then
they were like basically going into
their private banking all this stuff
they they uh they seized their gofundme
account did it they didn't disperse it
to the activists and whatever i'm like
what if that happened to the blm
movement there's a double standard here
going i don't know and i think
politically we'll find out because it's
you're right but there's also another
thing going on too where when blm was
going on big time like it was during the
crypto bear market a lot of faith was
out of the crypto market unfortunately
that was when you're supposed to be
buying the most in my opinion but but
you know now that we're here yeah we'll
see how it goes like going forward what
if another blm movement pops up and then
there's a gofundme or whatever and what
if the sitting president at the time
goes nope i'm gonna block that we'll see
how it goes that that might happen yeah
i don't know but it's just to me i just
don't like it how uh there's a double
standard in the government where they're
like oh yeah you guys are terrorists now
so let me just freeze your accounts but
they're citizens they're not terrorists
by the way how could how much worse
could it get for usd right now okay
you're talking about
you could hey at any time you want to
hold usd that's awesome but guess what
we might be able to freeze your account
at any time just so you know even if
you're international we could freeze
your account so that that's what and
then you know you might come in come at
me with like hey metamask just froze
some accounts today but actually what
they what happened was it was the end
point
is where they were able to freeze
metamask is an ethereum wallet where you
can um and actually transactions with a
bunch of stuff like cosmos and a bunch
of different blockchains but the idea is
that like you you have like a little hot
wallet right and you can use it to
transact on whatever blockchain you
choose to use like bnb or any other
stuff
but the end point when you when it's
time to cash out the endpoint is what
froze um
certain people from being able to cash
out going into a bank account exactly so
so that's it wasn't necessarily metamask
doing that it was the um endpoint
application that they use that froze it
and so that's a different conversation
but crypto's not supposed to behave like
that you're supposed to be able to have
your crypto on the stored on the
blockchain that means not using a
centralized exchange not using a
coinbase not using gemini any of that
stuff you're supposed to put this stuff
like maybe on a ledger or on um you know
any of those device there's a couple of
devices right that are out there but you
can store it on the blockchain yourself
and therefore you control it because if
it's not in your wallet with your keys
you don't truly control your crypto and
so that's the fear that people have yeah
and i want to bring
back to light something that you had
just brought up the idea of like you
know uh especially with us dollars banks
and stuff like that like
we're living in a time frame where the
idea that
a governing authority can freeze your
money and make it so you don't want to
access it like that's already very like
crazy that's crazy because we're not
[ __ ] like criminal drug dealers
exactly but then you're guilty to prove
an incident now there's like a more
macro thing that like you know
especially for like what gives me a
foundation of uh i guess
projective belief and understanding it
comes down to like everything around
it's not just crypto right it's like
we're living in a time where like
somebody can freeze your assets we're
also living uh you know in a post
generation where it's like after things
like 9 11 and the patriot act it's like
again under the guise of terrorism like
our privacies are stripped and like our
constitutional amendments have already
been like kind of uh in some subjective
ways and the things that we're okay with
are are different hey if you want to
take a terrorist to gitmo go for it i
don't care if they have constitutional
rights it's all [ __ ] you add that to
like even like imagine if everybody is
driving like electronic over wi-fi cars
in the future and then the government
has the ability to like stop your car
totalitarian control is something that
it's going that direction if people
don't
in essence wake up and realize that like
that's kind of like no it's a chip it's
a chipping away thing right so like when
when i remember when the whole mask and
the mandates and things came out
anyone who spoke out against it they're
just like well that's a slippery slope
like it's not totalitarianism i'm like
no no it's like it's it's basically
moving inch by inch and before you know
it oh where did your rights go and it's
because if you don't this is the whole
democratic process is we have to
question constantly establishment and we
have to have a conversation we have to
pressure our representatives to
represent us not corporations not to
have a you know little old boys but good
luck we can't afford that right because
they only work for what big money you
know special interest groups but then
the thing is like all other we're we're
getting pushback from other citizens
when everyone is trying to have a
conversation
to get accountability from our leaders
yeah fight each other not your leaders
right and then and then but people are
like well you should shut the [ __ ] up
and just obey because you're causing a
ruckus and i'm like but this is the
process that we're supposed to be doing
out here like this is what we're taught
we're supposed to debate we're supposed
to
talk this out see what people want we're
supposed to vote it out not just shut
down somebody because it's like i don't
agree with you and i don't know how it
got here it blows my mind but then also
i think when it comes to the concept of
defined money it's like the same concept
it's like we need something away from
the reaches of control
uh governments in my opinion shouldn't
control money because it's something
that is uh yours and if you believe in
private ownership it's something that
you should be able to freely trade with
another individual
but that's just my take on it and if
people want to argue that i'm like okay
let's go at it instead of just saying
shut the [ __ ] up you know like i think
that's the that's the biggest
disservice that's happening right now
yeah in our like modern time is just so
many people just want to tell others
just shut up about this and just follow
look when nancy pelosi and mike pence
can fist bump on the senate floor but
you can't fist bump with your neighbor
because they they don't want to even
have a conversation with you that's the
joke
is that they're playing yeah all
everybody into a frenzy making sure that
we don't talk to each other ever but
then the leadership gets to go hang out
have cocktail parties and nobody gives a
[ __ ] which which i think just to kind of
tie it all together is an important uh
element to why we're even having this
conversation of
decentralized versus centralized i think
that's a huge thing that so many of like
the normies and so they don't actually
fully understand but that's that's the
theme that's the theme of everything
that's going on that's decentralized
finance yeah the underwritten element of
every problem that's happening that's
involved with that space which is also
why we go back to things like tara luna
because it's such a a successful and
important decentralized entity we're
about to take ripple by the way we're
about to take ripple down right now we
passed cardano cardano's a piece of [ __ ]
anyway i've been talking about cardona
being pizza [ __ ] forever
we're about to pass ripple [ __ ]
unbelievable when it comes to crypto i
think there's so many
i guess uh ways to look at it right like
we're really focusing on our belief of
this new form of uh the concept of money
and decentralizing financing and like
our belief of the future of how this is
going to be utilized within the
community now there's that you know um i
guess philosophy behind it that the the
maybe even moral aspect of it but then
there's also the investment benefits of
it because
fiat which is us dollars government
money all this stuff right
the way that it's structured is
um it's kind of devalued over time
because when you have a a central bank
that prints money
it devalues your money and this is why
you hear from old folks oh back in my
day i used to be able to get a cup of
coffee for 10 cents right inflation
inflation because they keep printing
money and that's what took down the
roman empire a lot of big governments
they keep overspending and they keep
over printing
and um because they're overconfident
it's because they're overcome
overconfident they think their empire's
too big to fail but do you want these
guys to be in charge of your future and
you're going to be working hard you're
going to be saving up money you're going
to be putting this into you know your
safe investments and whatever but over
time you're gonna lose the value of all
the years and hours you worked for
because these you know idiots [ __ ] it
for you and so for me i'm like i don't
want them to have that power i rather
put it in something else where i control
it or the community controls it and the
value stays very strong for that reason
and so when you pick a good coin that
you see the great fundamentals behind it
takes a little bit of time to study this
and all that stuff but when you choose a
good one what ends up happening is
it skyrockets in price because people
are what's called like they're hedging
their money saying that if i believe you
know again this is going to go down in
value because they're over printing this
then i need to put it in something
that's going to go up in value so i'm
not losing my money and that's why
people invest in real estate that's why
some people believe in buying gold
that's why some people are like getting
things that that are called assets or
things of value and crypto is now one of
them because it's holding the value
because the us dollar is going down from
all the printing that they and listen
people might say like hey thanks steve
all this stuff it's very like it's all
very nice i'd love to hear it but but
but the point that i'm trying to make is
that you should arm yourself with the
knowledge that when you go home like you
go to you go to thanksgiving you go to
christmas you go at a birthday party
whatever you're at with a bunch of
people who don't know about this stuff
and they're telling you how stupid you
are because you bought it you can arm
yourself knowing enough about this stuff
to say nah that's not why no that's not
what's going on you don't understand
what i'm doing actually you think you do
you think you're an expert at this stuff
but you don't know
what's going on with this stuff and
because you can defend it is why you are
in the winning circle right now that's
why you won and they lost that's why you
won and most people who were buying
[ __ ] ripple or cardano or any of this
stuff but and it's all fine but the
token supplies are goddamn nuts bro
they're like [ __ ] it's just uh it's but
it's complicated man
they don't know what market cap is i
know but what edge could they have but
no dude knowing that like since last
year we're talking about things like
anchor protocol bro you were up with me
at three in the morning we're getting
anchor protocol
like the [ __ ] initial coin offering
for that
came right to our wallets and that same
night it the thing what we went down
like 60 i think right but but if you if
you look at what it was that we were
trying to do right
which was the plan we're like okay we're
gonna try to go in here it's gonna be
it's like it's going for like five cents
each at launch if we can just get in
there before it rides up maybe we can
get like a little 10x out of it we can
[ __ ] instant sell and like you know
we're just in line
i think you got kind of wrecked on that
one a little bit i think well mostly
moving money around mostly moving money
around but that happens in crypto right
so it's like just being transparent
about the game right but i paid for my
lessons and i won big baby but see
that's that's right i think that's one
of the biggest things that's deterring
like mass adoption still right now right
because
a centralized exchange is still it's
fairly safe yeah i mean you can use
coinbase and be pretty chill like i i
had i bought some bitcoin like five
years ago and forgot about it and i was
and
last year i was like oh [ __ ] i got a lot
of bitcoin a decent amount i have like
anyways um but like defy is still it's
still a much riskier investment it's
it's it's it's
it's way riskier than putting your money
in chase bank because
your money in chase bank is fdic insured
and you're not you're not getting any
interest off of it but if someone steals
your debit card and
charges uh ten thousand dollars on your
thing they're going to give your your
money back yeah you're gonna get it back
okay that's true if you get scammed on
defy on is there's a million it depends
because fd fdic insurance just came to
anchor protocol actually so there's a
bunch going on with this stuff that
people aren't aware of but that's the
utility they talk about right damn right
that's that's being an early adopter
right yeah it's all like it's about
being early if you're if you're early
because eventually this stuff is going
to catch on um you got to pick the right
i guess it's it's like value investing
like what warren buffett said like you
try to pick out the great companies that
are priced really low right now and
they're going to get better but that
takes time and research and
understanding but all all i'm saying is
that not financial advice but what steve
did say tara luna early on because he
did all that homework for you guys and
um he made me some hefty hefty cash you
know hey no but seriously congrats to
you guys because like it takes a lot to
stay in the game the game is not easy
the game is constant work
and yeah it's growing okay
yeah there is there is
when he would first start when we got in
though uh i i told you yo i'm this is
this is at least a five-year game for me
so i've seen the swings i've seen dude
my my swings are like from
seeing it to close to one mil drop in a
10 grand
and those numbers will make anybody off
themselves
but for me i was like party on dude i
got three more years to go to see the
numbers go
and um i'm sitting at seven figs baby
hey good job brother yeah oh yeah okay
and i'm still homeless so what's up
and by the way that was in 10 months
which is unbelievable but i guess you
could still say the same about stock
market right if you just started
investing in the stock market and you
don't know [ __ ] you could probably lose
a lot of money you got to you got it's
going to take a long time to learn how
to really play the game yeah but i
always say like you gotta you gotta play
big to win big you know that that you
gotta
work or
do what i did i think i put like
eighteen thousand dollars in total and
i'm over seven figs so so that's but
that's from research
that's from research that's from just
saying i'll do it twice let's go check
baby let's go let's go
[Music]
[Music]